watching after weeks of attacks and
troops trying to end the miners strike
president Gustavo Petro says he has had
enough
if the clan de Golfo is behind the
strike as the evidence shows then they
clearly have no will for peace
the president has ordered the Armed
Forces to reactivate military operations
against the clan delgolfo an armed group
that had previously agreed to a
ceasefire with the government it was the
latest setback for Petra's signature
policy of total peace in which he's
trying to negotiate agreements with
remaining Rebel groups while promoting
surrender deals with drug mafias in
exchange for judicial leniency
a policy that after showing progress has
been bogged down by armed groups taking
advantage of the truces conceded by the
government to gain territorial control
critics say that some of the setbacks
are the consequence of presidents
Petro's hurry to produce results his
majority in Congress may not last very
long and he only has one four-year term
to demonstrate that he and the political
left can change the country for the
better
the lead negotiator of the 2016
successful peace deal with far grebels
argues the government has been too
generous with the groups
armed groups have all the time in the
world gorillas don't have four-year
terms I think one of the suggestions is
that the government shouldn't show so
much anxiety supporters of the plan say
that criticism is unfair
we've already shown more results than
the previous government in four years
we have at least four solid negotiations
that are moving forward communities are
in a hurry not us
at some into
some internal servers say the government
needs to learn from mistakes already
made mainly in its more clarity on its
methods on its plan to pursue this
forward and it needs to work on a
serious security policy to protect the
population and to create incentives for
the peace negotiations to be successful
well everybody agrees on the
government's Goodwill some fear its
ambition could end up overwhelming its
chances of success